the fate of the universe is at stake
so mrs. at Edo ease together we can stop
him Avengers man
oops my deist heroes never heard of them
BTC at every windows fun feeding cool so
cool
Avengers infinity war Leslie together
pika Tracy
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more so when they
needed us we can fight the battles being
there
the end is near Avengers infinity war
April 27th
Tommy's name again Janice
we're gonna need some help let's go on
April 27
of ventures
once
I'm Peter dr. strange oh you should have
made up names um I'm spider-man then
Avengers infinity war
with a pg-13 sadness it could destroy
life on Earth
we're gonna need some help from April 27
together it's our only hope Avengers
join us once and for all
join us mightiest heroes not today sir
are you making your voice deeper y'all
the gun is my voice so cool Avengers
infinity war the pg-13 you're strong but
I could snap my finger and it all cease
to exist
before in time to see all the possible
outcomes
did we win any
it's a small price to pay
to salvation
Avengers infinity war with a pg-13 II
everywhere April 27th today we fight for
our lives on April 27th
group put that thing away
Avengers infinity war committee pg-13
April 27
you